question to ross from euphoricgr4674
as a journalist who understands we
didn't get all these names i'm gonna
have to change my name my name's far too
boring this is
[Laughter]
sorry
question to ross as a journalist who
understands the news cycle and you know
that the general public jumps from topic
to topic
what can we
do
i'm assuming he means as the public as
the people watching this what can we do
to keep the ufo story in the headlines
until the truth comes out in other words
how do we not lose the momentum on this
topic
oh boy that's a really good question
i don't think people actually realize
how powerful they are i mean really
i've i've sat in the offices of
ministers of government and seen how
they overreact to a dozen letters on an
issue
you know ministers staffers panic when
they get letters a good old-fashioned
handwritten typed letter that says i
want you to investigate blah i'm a i'm a
voter
i i influence a large number of people
in the electorate that i'm in which just
so happens to be a marginal electorate i
want you to do something about this you
know you're my political representative
act do something now
and so i really think the simplest thing
that people can do is let their
political representatives know that this
issue matters to them i mean i you know
you've got elections at the moment in
canada
and at the moment the big question is
will trudeau survive government
why aren't people asking him on the
campaign trail mr prime minister have
you been read into anything pertaining
to uaps why isn't the legitimate
question when the united states
government has admitted that the
phenomenon is real
you know what's the cognitive dissonance
here that means that even though the
pentagon has now acknowledged the
phenomenon is real
it cannot explain prosaically this
phenomenon
the mainstream media still to a large
degree treat it with a ridicule and
contempt
kind of a taboo and stigma
it has to change and
ultimately what people need to do is
get on the blower but don't do it in a
nutty way
you know say to a journalist excuse me
you're the national security writer for
the globe and mail or the national
security writer for the new york times
why did you pooh-pooh the whole issue of
ufos and that article you wrote the
other day you know why are you not
taking it seriously when the u.s
government is
you know are you aware of this issue
this issue and this issue that
legitimizes why this is a legitimate
area for investigation
hey have you read the book in plain
sight by ross coulthard
but
more importantly the other thing you can
do is
get on the blower or write actually
writing's really important a physical
letter makes a huge difference it could
be type of thing but as long as it's
printed typed
yeah people should just get on their
typewriter and write what do they use
these days their laptop and brighter
light
i grew up in journalism when you
actually did
carbons this is how old i am you wrote
carbons of your story and so i have to
have four bits of carbon paper and then
type on a typewriter of my story and
then i'd put a pin through the paper
and send different copies off to
different editors that's how we
circulated stories
and
you know it's amazing these days because
we now live in a in an age where it's
very easy to distribute information
but that old-fashioned way of
distributing information in a letter i
found it an extraordinarily powerful
research tool when i was writing my book
because it was a way of
protecting sources because snail mail to
a large degree is not intercepted still
it is intercepted sometimes but not as
much as
emails or other forms of electronic
communication
and so
there's enormous power in writing a
letter to a minister of government
saying
or
or even you know for example if you're a
tv reporter or
uh just an activist journalist
politely you know don't be nasty about
it respectfully i found the best way is
to be respectful and honorable to people
and give them a break
you know get a camera next time you know
hillary clinton somewhere say oh mrs
clinton hi my name's joe blogs i'm a
citizen podcast activist interested in
ufos
she might start walking away can i ask
you what you were talking to um john
podesta about in 2016.
you know what were you talking about
when you said in this email blah blah
blah blah blah
you know people need to ask the nuts and
bolts questions we need to drill down
and actually do some serious research
for example just the other day i am i've
written a letter to a guy who
claims in a book
that jfk wrote a memo on the 12th of
november 1963
that asked the director of the cia
to collate
ufo information that was sensitive for
national security so that it could be
shared with the russians
now i hasten to wear
he claimed the writer claims that he'd
obtained that memo on freedom of
information from the cia
and there was an article that was
published in the media that said
immediately that
the provenance of that memo was in
question because when they checked at
the jfk library they couldn't find any
such memo
and so you were left at the end of all
of the articles that were published
about this guy's book with the
impression that that 12th of november
1963 memo was a fake it was a hoax
either he was hoaxed or you know
somebody had done it
so i thought back at this i want to know
so i tracked down the guy last night and
i've emailed him and i've if i don't
hear from him i'll post him a letter but
i want to know i want to ring him and
find out what the hell is going on
what's the truth of that claim did he
actually foi and did he obtain that
document on foi
and if i can find out that he did obtain
that document on foi
why then were all these articles written
in the media asserting that it couldn't
be a real document
who instigated those articles was it
disinformation
so that's the way my brain works you
know i'm an investigative journalist and
so i don't take any fact for granted i
have to test those facts and and verify
verify them for myself
and
that's where i'm at basically i'm
constantly checking things and so people
should do that so one of the things that
has come up a bit in today's
conversation is people have often said
you know what do you think about blah
and
a lot of that is unverifiable you know i
can't verify alien abductions or
experiences i can't
but if there are specific incidents like
you know one of the things that i have a
b in my bonnet about is the way that
nasa never responds have you noticed
this they never respond to those weird
shots there's one in particular that
gets my imagination going
of an object that's shot from the space
station or from a
spacecraft of some kind looking down on
the planet and what you see is an object
that's moving along and then a light
flashes from the planet below and
interestingly enough it's over north
western australia which is why i'm
interested in it and the object reacts
before the light hits it and then just
goes
and moves off
now i haven't seen i have what can i say
uh look it's in the in endless numbers
of nasa space objects i'm sure some of
your listeners will know about it before
the end of this conversation they will
have posted it
but it really does look amazing and so
i've approached nasa i've approached
different space experts and i've said
can anybody explain this
now
because i'm not in america or i'm not
able to go to the nasa archives i can't
go and verify
that particular piece of film from
i think it was the space shuttle
uh to see whether or not it really was
on that sts on that particular space
shuttle mission
but people need to do the work to
actually go okay
here is a potential mystery
here's an issue that can be investigated
let's drill down and test the provenance
of the claims that have been made about
this video
what if we can show that it is a real
nasa video
then we go to a defense reporter on a
major national newspaper and we say okay
we've done the homework for you because
most of these reporters don't have the
time this is the reality from my time in
commercial television we're working in
freeway most of them don't have the time
to do this kind of grunt investigative
journalism
if you go to them and say hey listen
this is the work we've done we're a ufo
transparency group you may think we're
crazy but have a look at this these are
the source documents from nasa we've
gone to nasa's own archives this film
came from this
time period in this shuttle mission
here's the proof you can find it on this
file in this archival document on the
nas's files
look at it
what's that like what's that
objectivating what the hell's going on
here
you know the thing that irritates me is
the number of times things get posted
onto the web
by people who think they're doing the
right thing in ufology
and they haven't done the basic checks
before they put it up there
and then immediately what happens is
somebody just goes oh yeah that's
[ __ ]
and it dies dies on the vine
what people need to do is become
cleverer
they need to test the evidence first
before they put it up there and so
that's why frankly i have a lot of
trouble with the blurry videos of
distant objects that people endlessly
post on the web because they can be
faked so easily they're so useless
they're so helpless
but what if you can go back through
as i know you can
[Music]
and this is interesting edgar mitchell
sat on a couch with my friend the
spaceman
and showed him
the original
digitized nasa films of the lunar
landings
and pointed out to him things that he
edgar said were anomalous
and i've seen them i've sat there with
the spaceman and watched them and gone
[ __ ] he's right
and
this is the thing that really blows me
away is there could be a whole area of
ufo investigation that actually
seriously engages with the content that
nasa itself has broadcast
and when nasa refuses to answer
go to your congressman and say
sorry can we get a question posed please
at the senate armed services committee
or at the nasa oversight committee can
we get a question asked about why
they're refusing to answer questions
from citizens who are paying their tax
bill
because people forget these are publicly
funded organizations they are
accountable to you the public
you own them
they're yours they may not like
admitting that but they're your
institutions they have to be accountable
to you
and one of the things that to me just
great as a journalist is that people
don't understand their rights to ask
they might refuse
but if they do refuse you put that up in
lights nasa has refused to answer a
reasonable question about x y and z
why
then you go to your next congressman and
you say well you're senator and you say
senator will you ask a question in the
federal congress about you know why
nasa's refusing to answer questions then
you turn it into a huge issue
i mean look at the momentum that was
developed for that stupid raid area 51
thing you know people people thought
well remember that
yeah imagine if instead of raid area 51
it was
um nasa tell the truth
you know explain these videos explain
the anomalies
imagine if there was a sensitive
scientist
a sensible scientific engagement with
the anomalous objects that have
repeatedly been cited on nasa missions
many of which nasa has
not been able to explain
well we'll see if we can get that
popularized this hashtag nasa tell the
truth
after
once this video is reposted
now kurt you've exhausted me mate so i
really don't know how much longer i can
go yeah okay well then how about let's
break it down into three steps for the
people who are watching just the
audience not journalists okay so what
should they do first search google for
local represent like what are they let's
break it down into three concrete steps
what do they do
okay
don't be insulting
political representatives are just going
to throw your letter in the mail if
you're rude or impolite or if you come
across as a crazy person
so be respectful
ask
don't just dash off a stupid email that
doesn't ask a question write a really
cleverly considered carefully written
letter
so for example let's just use as an
example than nasa objects
somebody needs to go to the nasa
archives and search those archives for
the film vision that is regularly posted
up on youtube saying you know where
somebody says hey look at this no
shuttle mission sts-16
uh at 21 minutes 30 there's a object
that does x y and z
somebody needs to go and prove that in
the files and prove that and get the
actual data and write it all out do the
research so maybe there's somebody here
from florida who can go and sit down in
nasa or in houston or wherever it is
do that research collaborate
and this is the thing i've learned as a
journalist i'm a member of this group
called icij where we for example
investigated the panama papers the
leaked papers that showed who was
evading tax by having
tax shelters in the bahamas and other
places like that and we all collaborated
so there was a a guy in belgium who
could do a property search for me in
belgium and i could do a lens title
search in sydney and we could share data
it's cool it's a really cool thing to do
you guys can do this in the world of
uaps ufos you can share data
be intelligent don't just shove a bloody
video up and go oh look what i found i
beat everybody else to it by putting it
up here and then it immediately gets
shot down in flames
don't put it up there until you've
verified its provenance
if you can
so you know go to nasa get the data and
then put together a considered letter
dear senator
please find attached uh an mpv file or
whatever wv file which shows vision of
an object that was shot from the space
shuttle endeavour on blah date on
blood time
on this mission
i know this and i can verify this
because
this is the file number of where this is
stored in the nasa archive and i have
this proved copy of that data which i
obtained from nasa under foi
i put it to you sir that this shows an
anomalous intelligently controlled
object maneuvering in our orbit
and it is clearly a space vehicle of
some kind
that is not human
can i please ask why this is not being
investigated if there is a legitimate
national security reason for why we're
not being told the truth about this can
this please be explained to me
i am representative of an organization
that represents 5 000 people um you know
maybe it's mufon i don't know
uh you know please sir kindly could i
request that you direct your questions
to this the next meeting of the nasa
oversight committee you know this is how
you do it
be respectful
you never know
the mood in the congress at the moment
is really interesting i'm talking to
congressmen senators and their staffers
they're waiting for
the public
to show they want this
because i don't think it's going to
happen i'm not of the view that there's
going to be transparency any more than
what we've got at the moment i think
we've been sold a pup
i think that the uap task force
really only largely came about because
of the activism of the ttsa people
good people like louis lozando
christopher mellon
and tom de la
what he's done is amazing all credit to
tom frankly what he's done is absolutely
amazing he's brought this ahead far more
than i think anybody realized he ever
would
but there's nothing going to happen
there's certainly not going to be public
hearings or congressional hearings
unless the public make it clear
intelligently
and firmly that they do want it and that
these are the reasons why and these are
the things that should be investigated
so when people send me experience of
videos and say you know i've seen this
object hovering at 20 000 feet and all i
see is a white dot moving across the sky
what the hell am i meant to do with that
no disrespect to the people that sent it
to me but seriously i can't verify its
provenance i don't know what you've done
with it
but let's think intelligently let's look
at the things that we know come from
government itself like for example the
nimitz sighting
you know we know for a fact that the
reason why the government's been forced
into the position that it's being passed
into at the moment is largely because of
the
incredible work that was done by
different people to expose what was
revealed in the nimitz data
and the reason that why that was so
efficacious was because there is clearly
vision
which was confirmed by sensor systems
and what i've been told uh bob fish who
was one of my informants that went on
the record in my book he he's a guy with
extremely high security clearances who
is aware of the reality of the
phenomenon he's been briefed about
anomalous objects that have been seen on
satellites and
seen coming in and out of the ocean he
tells me
he told me that people should be looking
at the um
the data the the kind of data that would
be being collected by
the e2 hawkeye aircraft you're talking
about telemetry data
not just radar data you're talking about
very high level
electromagnetic data communications data
measuring the frequencies of those
objects
that telemetry data would exist and
nobody apparently has foider let's say
for why that
so there are ways of investigating this
in a rigorous scientific
objective way and as best i can i'm i'm
asking questions myself
but i am a little frustrated with the
tendency on ufo twitter for people to
seize across every new crazy rumor and
it's really not helping frankly it just
paints you all as a bunch of bloody
loonies and you're not i know you're not
you know there is something real there
the government's confirmed that it's
real
but by continuing just to post blurry
videos and
you know uncorroborable uh witness
accounts it's really not helping
what people need to do is become far
more methodical and clever
and and it's interesting because
if you look at your history
way back in the 1950s
the people who were driving the push for
disclosure the lou elizondos and the
christopher mellons of their day
they included people on nycap
like
roscoe helencotter a former director of
the central intelligence agency
why the hell was a former director of
the cia
actively pushing for disclosure by the
us government of what it knew about the
phenomenon
clearly he believed that the u.s was
hiding something
70 years ago
and here we are 70 years later
and it's the same old cycle
so it's very very easy to think that it
might be possible that we're just being
bought off with another lame
promise that they're going to do some
kind of ufo oversight inside the
congress or inside the office of the
under secretary of defense intelligence
but that the the secret the real secrets
will be kept for another 50 to 100 years
i wouldn't be surprised at all if they
were because people aren't pushing
they're not using the powers that they
have in the congress to actually demand
that the congressman ask questions and
they need to ask arm their congressman
and congresswoman with the sort of
questions that need to be being asked
and they need to be intelligent
questions not dumb whack-up job
questions that make people sound like
loops
no no and try and limit the number of
stamps you put on the envelope because
if it's more than four stamps i
generally think you're crazy
and sorry i'm not being flippant here
but you know the um well i am being
clifford but i mean i i do think there's
a serious message here is that that
ufology needs to wake up to itself
it is right i mean people get angry with
um
skeptical questioning by people like
john greenwald of the black vult i'm a
fan of john i love what he does and he
he should be answering asking questions
you know and and mick west for example
god bless him the don quixote of
skeptics tilting at that windmill but
you know we need people like that it's
really important that that
the claims made be tested
and i've been pulled up on a few things
where people have said to me well how do
you know that you know they're using uh
the frequencies that they can detect
these objects by to bring them down
because i've recently talked about the
fact that um
there is uh stories that are
uncorroborated that the united states
might be trying to think about bringing
down one of these objects
and even though i've said it a hundred
times
i don't know it
i don't but what i'm reporting is what
i've been told
and sometimes maybe it's not a good idea
to report those things maybe it's better
just to keep your mouth shut let's deal
objectively with what we do know
what we do know is that there is a
phenomenon that is unexplained
and it's been admitted to be unexplained
by the most powerful country on the
planet
there are objects that appear to be
intelligently controlled craft that are
maneuvering
hypersonic maneuvers
they're capable of doing all manner of
weird things
and the government admits
it's real
that's a pretty good start for people to
start writing to their congressman and
demanding action
demanding oversight hearings
and one of the things that they'll be
very very sensitive about is the
questions about the black budget
because really in the last 30 years not
much has come out of area 51
and yet
trillions of dollars have been spent in
the black budget
where u.s taxpayers if they actually
added it all up have no bloody idea
where their money's gone
there are literally
dozens
hundreds of black projects where money's
been sunk into things and the public
haven't been told what it was for
now for all their faults
the one thing the generals are worried
about the one thing the people spending
the money are worried about is having to
account for that money
and believe me
when the questions asked they will have
to answer
so it's the good old political maximum
the wheel that squeaks gets to greece if
you want action to happen you have to
become
it's not enough just to bleat on social
media
not gonna work
if you've got the time to sit down and
pin some poisonous venom on social media
for half an hour
why not just sit down and find out the
name of your political representatives
and write to them
and say this matters to you and i'm not
crazy
you know i'm a i'm a doctor or a lawyer
or a businessman and i actually think
that there is something really serious
behind this phenomenon and i want you my
political representative to take it
seriously i want transparent open
hearings in the congress and if not why
not and this will affect my vote
end of later
i like that
okay ross thank you so much you've
been extremely generous with your time
i'm gonna say goodbye to the audience
and then we'll just speak for a minute
off air
sure lovely talk to you
goodbye everyone thank you so much
there's been i think a thousand people
at its max and it's been hovering at
around 850 people constantly so thank
you
i'm gonna stop the stream and then ross
let's
talk
i asked ross to give me three steps that
those who are interested in the ufo
phenomenon can take in order to get the
government to release more information
on this topic
he sent me seven steps
here they are number one pick an issue
pertaining to uaps that offer an
opportunity to perhaps independently
verify or debunk the claims made about
it for example in the case of sts-48
that is the 1991 shuttle mission there's
been a plethora of claims on the
internet with debunkers saying it's
clearly ice and the conspiracists
asserting its et
number two to the end of resolving the
matter assess whether it adequately
explains all the issues raised by the
evidence in this case i've read the
popular science explanation by james
oberg
but nothing adequately addresses the
flash of light you see at a considerable
distance from the shuttle
what could this be
number three
let's obtain the original data in this
case it would be nasa's own vision and
the other data james oberg cites in his
paper number four assess the data and
see if there are unanswered questions
remaining if there are unanswered
questions then number five write a
polite and careful letter to your
congressman congresswoman
setting out why you believe this is an
unresolved mystery that is worthy of
official engagement by your political
representative number six if this letter
gets ignored publish your research
efforts online and show people the
efforts you've made to verify the
reality behind the observed phenomenon
this is extremely important this is
kurt's note now this step is the most
important because otherwise we'll have
people saying well look i've reached out
well what's your evidence that you've
reached out you're asking for them to
provide evidence how about you provide
some evidence that you've actually done
the work and have filed let's say an foi
claim or have sent a physical letter to
a congress person then ross says that
the number seven step which is the last
step is move on to the next claim best
wishes and warm thanks ross coldheart
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jymungal it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you
you